As I sit here in the middle of February,
we're about eight months away from
Election Day,
2016.
Doesn't that sound completely insane?
I mean,
think about it.
We've been talking about this election
for at least a year and we're still over
half a year away from it.
That is completely bonkers.
So much of the election process is just
insider nonsense and day to day per so
it's hard to focus on what issues are
actually important.
Not only does the 24 hour cable news
cycle thrive on election drama and
distractions,
but the entire process of electing our
politicians seems to be built on getting
the people to actually never talk about
the big issues in an honest way.
We have debates with catered questions
and no actual debating.
We have town halls which are just forums
for talking points and social media
campaigns to spread candidates messages
without ever explaining how their ideas
will actually solve anything.
You know,
there's a strange collusion between the
media and politicians to keep us all in
the dark about what's really going on
here.
What I actually want to hear candidates
talking about are big ideas.
Not Political talking points to explain
their economic philosophy and how it
came to be,
to say how they came up with a moral
argument for or against abortion and to
let us know why America's role in the
world should be larger or smaller.
Unfortunately,
big ideas don't fit into 32nd
soundbites,
leaving us with a media that wants views
and clicks instead of substantive debate
and a political class who of course are
all the happier to provide meaningless
slogans that sound good in a headline
but don't mean anything at all.
That brings me to the two people really
shaking up the system.
At this point.
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump.
Bernie says he wants a political
revolution.
While trump says he wants to make
America great again,
I doubt they'll ever be another
candidate like Bernie,
a world weary lifelong politician who
wants to fundamentally change how things
operate from the inside.
Whether you agree or disagree with him.
It's a powerful message that of course
there is trump,
a billionaire who's using years of board
room and TV experience to give his
supporters whatever they want.
Even if they don't know exactly what
that is,
what these two men have in common though
is more interesting.
They both openly mock the powerful and
corrupting influence of money in
politics while only existing as
legitimate contenders because of its
very existence.
It shouldn't be lost on us that it's
actually the very strength of our
democratic system that allows to people
who want to totally upend it to be
surging in the polls and as warped as
our system is.
If the two guys who were the most
plainspoken who were being heard the
loudest,
although the countdown to election 2016
frustrates me as a political junkie,
I can't pretend that I don't enjoy the
clown show.
It's a soap opera with characters you
just can't make up.
I mean,
we've got the ex president's wife,
the Socialist Jew,
the billionaire and the neurosurgeon.
It basically sounds like a spinoff of
Gilligan's island.
Unfortunately,
while Gilligan and his friends were
eventually rescued from their island,
the only ones who can rescue from this
shipwreck ourselves,
the citizens to help me navigate these
choppy waters this week is my guest,
Ben Shapiro,
the editor@largeofBreitbart.com.
Many of you have asked us to have a sit
down to dig into some of his
conservative ideas,
can have liberal and a conservative
coexist well.
If thirstin howl,
the third and ginger could do it.
I have a feeling that ben and I will be
able to as well.
Every election year,
politicians remind us that their
election is the most important of a
generation.
Usually that's just more hyperbole
nonsense,
but this time it could actually be true
regardless of who wins,
whether it's one of these to hillary or
Jeb or the skipper.
Our system is fundamentally shaking
right now,
as evidenced by both the sanders and
trump surgeries.
Can we address real issues in the months
to come or will we keep talking about
sideshow nonsense?
Can we get a fair election system or
will big donors always run the show?
Can we elect officials who will
compromise to make the country stronger
or will partisan points always win the
day?
These are just a few of the huge issues
we have to discuss and that's not even
touching on immigration,
healthcare and terrorism.
A lot of people mock the idea of
American exceptionalism,
especially on the left,
but I actually do believe in it.
There has never been a country in the
history of the globe that is taken more
people from across the world and help
them make a better life for themselves,
their children,
and their children's children.
Even now with all of our problems,
people still want to come to America for
a better life.
We have massive issues,
but underneath it all,
there's a bedrock based in democratic
principles which still makes our
position in the world truly unique.
It doesn't mean America can or should
tell the world what to do,
but it does mean we have a
responsibility to be fairer,
freer,
and more functional whenever we can.
All of these reasons are why I've made
this show about ideas and not my new
show.
There is an endless cycle of noise
designed to keep us distracted and
divided.
Our politicians will only be better if
we demand they be better.
Will only demand our politicians be
better if we are better ourselves.
As you guys know,
I love to say the two things can be true
at the same time.
Maybe we can have a political revolution
while at the same time making America
great again.
This change doesn't start with trump and
sanders though it starts with the
government of the people,
by the people and for the people.
Just as the great Gilligan once said,
my
guest this week is editor in chief of
daily wire.com,
editor@largeofBreitbart.com,
a syndicated columnist and radio host
and in New York Times best selling
author.
You want me to throw in anything else
and then you've got a serious resume.
I mean,
I was doing some research on.
You pretty much do everything.
Yeah.
All right.
Well I'm.
I'm very happy that you're here because
I had all of twitter basically saying to
me for about six months you've got to
talk to this guy.
This is the guy who will either convert
you to conservatism or you guys are just
going to hate each other.
Turned into flaming Bernie Sanders.
Socialist.
Yeah,
that's,
that's pretty much pretty sure.
That's not the direction.
It'll be a conservative by the end of
the conversation.
So.
Well,
let's see.
Let's allocate territory.
Yeah,
let's see what happens.
But,
but a lot of people also said that even
even liberals that,
that.
No.
Have you said I don't agree with this
guy and a lot sometimes I don't even
like him,
but there's some principle based around
what he does.
So that's pretty much of what I do here.
So that's why I wanted to have you on.
Thanks for having me.
I got a lot of requests to come on your
show.
Somebody invited me.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's get to it.
So first off,
you were actually born in La and brought
up in La.
I thought there were no conservatives in
La.
What the hell are you doing here?
So my parents were both.
They voted for Carter and 76 and they
were Reagan Republicans.
And then because we're orthodox Jews,
religious Jews tend to vote Republican
and be culturally conservative and so
that sort of the million in which I grew
up,
so I became conservative basically from
birth I,
I'm not,
I'm not a new convert.
Right.
So how is that growing up a conservative
as a kid?
Because what's that saying?
You know,
if you're not liberal in your twenties,
you have no a heart and if you're not
conservative and you're 37 or something
like that,
how is that as a kid?
It's hard.
So it works out beautifully.
Well,
how,
how does,
how is that as a kid growing up,
your conservative as a kid?
It doesn't,
it just doesn't sound.
It doesn't sound right.
Somehow,
again,
growing up in religious communities a
little bit different than growing up in
a nonreligious communities.
Religious communities tend to be more
conservative.
And in La,
conservatism is all about social issues,
right?
When it comes to economics,
there's kind of the,
the LDLC,
the people driving around in the
Mercedes Benz with a Bernie sanders
sticker,
but everybody knows the full of it.
So it's a lot of that in beverly hills
right now.
Oh yeah.
And it's like,
okay,
you can just drive down to cars for
kids.
I think any day now just give it away
and you enjoy yourself.
Like I don't understand why you need my
money.
You clearly have some of your own.
So anytime.
But in la it's all a cultural thing and
conservative versus versus leftist.
And I like to distinguish leftist from
liberals because I don't think they're
the same thing.
A conservatives versus leftists in La is
very much about kind of a character
assumption if he or if you're a leftist,
you're a good person and if you're a
conservative that means you're an
uptight John Lithgow type from
footloose.
You don't want anybody to.
That's what it comes down to.
Right.
So I definitely want to dig into the
difference between liberals and
leftists,
you,
because it's something you focused on a
lot from the right.
And it's something that I've focused on
a lot in the last year from the left.
So we're going to dive into that,
but let's just do some election stuff.
Sure.
First,
let's get the easy stuff.
Fun stuff.
All right,
so this election seems completely insane
to me.
Uh,
let's start with trump.
You're big on trump.
I don't think so.
How you feeling?
I think that.
I think trump's a loud mouth.
I think he's a braggart.
I think that,
that trump is bad for American politics.
I think that there's a couple of things
that I like about trump won,
is that he says things that are not
politically incorrect.
The problem with trump is that he fails
to distinguish politically correct from
just being a jackass.
So there,
there is a difference.
I mean there's a difference between
being rude and being politically
incorrect.
Right?
Being being rude is telling Megan Kelly,
she's bleeding from her wherever.
Being politically incorrect is saying
that some immigrants across our southern
border are criminals.
That's politically incorrect,
but it's not rude.
But saying that Megan Kelly's bleeding
from her wherever,
that's not politically incorrect.
That's just being a jerk.
So,
so it was part of it that his people
mistake the two.
So because.
Because the,
the reign of political correctness is so
strong,
people have now interpreted being
politically incorrect as just anything
you say that pisses someone off,
that means you're politically incorrect.
And that's not what political
incorrectness is.
Sure.
So it's this conflation of just saying
anything and he's really good at that.
I mean,
I've noticed the more I watched him,
it really,
you can whittle him down to some pretty
basic stuff because he just says a lot
of circular logic stuff and this
person's great,
that person's great and they love me and
they hate me and that and that.
And he was actually never really saying
anything.
But that is sort of the genius,
what I don't like about him.
And it is the genius of him because we
live in a me culture and to me time and
uh,
me media.
And so trump is all about trump.
I mean,
that's,
that's really the only thing that
matters to him.
So if latimer potent insults him
tomorrow,
that matters more than a flat,
unrepentant invade a country because all
that matters is trump.
And so he speaks about himself in third
person and everything that he talks
about is,
I'm going to do this,
I'm going to build a wall,
I'm going to fix it.
I'm going to make a great deal.
I'm good for the blacks.
I'm good for the Hispanic.
Nowhere in there do I hear as a
conservative?
Nowhere in there.
Do I hear anything about what's the
proper role of government in my life,
which is the part that I care about,
right?
The part I don't care about Donald
Trump,
right?
I don't think he cares about me.
I don't think that we should care about
each other,
but I want him to leave me alone.
I want Barack Obama.
I want all these people to leave me
alone so I can live with that for a
conservative principle.
They're just.
Yes.
Just just leave me alone.
Like the government was not meant to do
this many things.
End of story.
I mean read the Constitution is very
explicit about the things government is
supposed to do and pretty much nothing
on trump's list except for maybe border
security is really something that the
government ought to be doing.
And,
and again,
what that comes down to,
and this is the problem,
is I think that what the danger of trump
is that the left for 100 years has
fallen in love with the idea of the
strong man.
I mean,
you go all the way back to Woodrow
Wilson and Woodrow Wilson is writing
about the president should be the
strongest man possible.
The only limits on his power should be
his vision basically,
which,
you know,
could come straight from Mussolini and
Woodrow Wilson was actually as close to
a dictator is America has ever had,
that's carried through to FDR is credit
to Lbj,
to Obama on the right.
At least they made overtures toward.
We're not going to have the strong man
who gets involved in your life and fix
all your problems.
Trump is the strong man and I think
after,
after so many years of a lot of
Americans on the right feeling
emasculated by President Obama telling
them that they're racist,
sexist,
bigot,
homophobes,
and by Hillary Clinton and telling them
that we're there to kind of testosterone
in orientation toward the world.
Basically.
I wrote this yesterday.
I think that the response to trump from
the right has basically been he's the
biggest swing instead of balls in the
race and because that's what he is.
I'm forum and you hear that from trump
supporters.
Well,
he'll do something.
Maybe he will.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Will it be good?
My question is a conservative though.
So as a truth,
this must make you feel crazy,
right?
I mean you must be really enraged at
your own party because it's looking more
and more everyday like he's actually to.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know to be most pest out
honestly.
I mean,
have you got.
You've got the gop establishment,
which can I get off the Jeb Bush,
ran for the life of them and then just
unify behind somebody like a Marco Rubio
and hate Ted Cruz.
So much they would side with trump over
Cruz,
probably cruise to them as too far right
crews and they think he's unelectable
and more than that cruise actually I
think believes the things they say they
believe so he says,
I believe in small government.
I think that we should cut the
government.
I think the government shouldn't be
important in people's lives and the RNC,
which makes its money off government
being important to people's lives.
I mean,
how much money would you give to a
political party if the government didn't
matter in your life or the RNC would
raise $0 if no one cared what happened
in Washington DC and so Cruz scares them
from that angle.
I don't think trump scares them.
I think trump,
trump annoys the establishment,
but he doesn't scare the establishment,
so I'm annoyed at the establishment.
I'm annoyed at.
You know,
Cruz is,
is a very good constitutional
conservative,
but he's just an unfair.
He's not a great candidate by any
stretch of the imagination,
and then there are the trump people who
are so populist and in love with the,
the,
the feel of trump that they forget that
they are,
that this guy could actually be
president and like if he's president and
what is that going to look like?
So it's,
it's,
it's frustrating.
Definitely all the way across the board.
And I think maybe the most frustrating
thing of all is that beating trump is
actually not that hard.
Trump is a school yard bully and
somebody needs to just say to him in the
last debate,
it was so clear.
If you actually want to stop trump,
you can't do a job dead,
whichever.
I mean,
Jeb stood there and he said,
you know,
Donald's,
you're,
you're bullying people.
And also stopping me and my mother
really.
I mean all trump is.
If my thesis is correct that basically
trump just represents the balls of
American politics and the only way to
beat that as to kick him in the balls.
Right?
I mean that figuratively speaking,
it's the only way to do it.
And he can't really or could work
through and it might work literally.
I mean,
um,
but,
but the only way to really beat him is
for somebody on the stage to say to him,
Donald,
you're,
you act like a big tough guy.
Your Papa gave you $40,
million dollars to play with.
You've never had anyone say no to you
and your entire life,
you're a pathetic week specimen.
Every time somebody takes you off,
you turned as red as the background on
that stage.
The other night.
I mean,
he actually faded into the woodwork
during that debate.
And if anybody on the stage really needs
to shut the hell up and just listen for
a second,
it might be used since you clearly know
nothing about anything.
So what does that tell you about the
rest of these guys?
That nobody does it.
I get it.
It's not in Jim's character,
right?
It's just not there.
I don't think it's in any of their
character.
What does that say then about this,
this group of people?
This is why they lose.
I mean,
it isn't Obama's character upon would do
it and I think it's actually in
Hillary's character.
I think these.
I think that folks on the left
understand that presidential politics is
a knife fight and people on the right
are constantly engaged in this game
where it's a discussion over policy.
So Jeb Bush this morning,
for example,
he's on,
he's talking about trump and he says
something to the effect of,
you know,
my,
my goal as president of the United
States is to grow our GDP from a two
percent growth rate to a four percent
growth rate.
I thought,
yeah,
that's going to be trump.
That's solid argument.
Like they don't understand that most
politics comes to.
It's unfortunate.
This is the way it is.
Most politics comes down to character
arguments.
Once you get the character off the
table,
then you can have a good policy argument
that most people on the left like to
turn and say to people on the right that
you are just bad people.
You're a racist,
sexist,
bigot,
homophobes,
so we shouldn't listen to you.
And,
and that's what trump does so well.
And so what you see on the right is,
yeah,
but you're not a conservative.
That's,
that's an argument about policy.
It's not an argument about character.
Right?
So for a guy that obviously doesn't like
Bernie Sanders or Hillary Clinton,
do you at least envy the fact that in
their debates,
it seems to me that it's much more
substantive.
There's at least,
you know,
they're really saying I'm the
progressive on the progressive.
Now you may hate all progressive ideas,
but at least there's a,
you know,
your,
you,
you got the d plus from the NRA and I
got to see her.
So a little more of that.
So I think that they stay away from the
character attacks,
which,
which I appreciate that.
That's good.
Although I think that,
you know,
in,
in Hillary's case,
some character attacks would be
necessary if Bernie actually would like
to win and not just run a campaign.
At some point he's going to have to say
your corrupt,
because that's sort of saying it though
right now,
and it's a little late,
right?
I mean,
and,
and by the way,
she's vicious.
I mean,
attacking him as a racist,
I,
I'll say a lot of bad things about
Bernie Sanders,
but calling Bernie Sanders is racist,
is absurd.
And then she's so set on I have to win
the ethnic minority vote that I'll send
out my surrogates like David Brock to
suggest he doesn't care about black
lives,
which is absurd.
You know,
I,
I think that I'd like to see a little
more character attacks on the,
on the left in between them anyway.
And uh,
and as far as policy,
I've watched a couple of their debates.
I have yet to see a significant area of
disagreement.
I think they're just coming at it from.
We agree on everything.
It's just a question of how we talk
about it to Bernie says,
let's talk about it honestly.
And Hillary says,
let's lie about it a little bit so that
people don't really figure out what
we're up to and then we'll do it and
it'll be too late.
Right.
So I sense at least with them,
there's a,
there's a hillary's trying to hit
burning on this that you're a big idea
guy,
but actually I can get some of this
stuff done now.
I don't know that the Republicans would
be any more inclined to say that birth
order.
I mean they say that,
but it's boring.
Right?
Kristy was saying that in every debate,
right?
You'd have Rubio and Cruz go at each
other and then there's Chris Christie
doing the La Jolla shores.
Governor.
I don't understand what you're saying.
What are you talking about?
Other.
Yeah,
because.
Because it's because it's a,
it's a dumb thing to do.
I mean he sounds like a,
he,
he acts like a hick when he does that.
Christie,
like if you're a governor of a major
state acting like you don't know how the
political game is played or like you
don't know what the Senate does.
I just don't know what these people are
arguing about over here.
Exactly.
Here I am,
you know,
I do real things like hug Obama.
Is it?
Come on.
So it's all the politics.
Everybody is playing politics right now.
At this level,
and nobody's playing politics like we're
the real ideologies are,
which is why I would like to see what I
would love to see.
I think it'd be good for the country is
a sanders versus Cruz raise.
Right?
That would actually be a fascinating
race because at that point may,
if standards can stay away from the
whole you're a racist,
sexist,
bigot,
homophobic thing.
We could actually have a discussion
about whether socialism is a good idea
or a bad idea.
Is income inequality something that we
ought to worry about or is it just
ramifications of a free market system in
which people make voluntary transactions
happen?
It's that these would be interesting
conversations,
but we,
we just don't get to them.
Right.
So the real of ideas
though,
be if it was sanders and had rand Paul
not dropped that,
you know,
my,
my problem with Rand Paul was always on
foreign policy.
I'm not an isolationist and so ran sort
of is,
but it's.
But yeah,
I mean that,
that it would be a battle of ideas that
would be worthwhile.
Yeah.
So the Republican Party in general,
and I hear this a lot on the left,
you know that it's this group of
homophobes and racist and all this stuff
and I've been fighting against this.
I've been fighting from the liberal side
against the regressive left.
What I,
you know,
the people that are on the far left to
me and I saw something interesting that
you retweeted it and remind me who said
this,
but somebody made a point of saying that
this morning Nikki Haley and an Indian
American is a and Tim Scott and African
American have both endorsed Marco Rubio
who is Latin.
These are all Republicans.
So in Indian,
a black person and a Latino and these
are Republicans and Tim Scott is a black
Republican from the south.
Somehow that messaging doesn't really
make it through,
does it?
Well it doesn't because they're not real
black people are real Latino's or real
forerunner of,
of,
of foreign extraction.
I mean,
Nikki Haley was born here,
but her parents are from India.
The,
that never
the point.
Isn't that the point of America?
That's what I would think.
Right?
But we,
we've,
we've broken down into this identity
politics that really is quite sad and
traps people in,
in a group identity rather than you're
an individual go out and make something
of yourself.
Go out and do something,
and this is a message that it's not
popular in,
in certain quarters.
When you say to people,
look,
your life is in your own hands.
There's a lot of responsibility that
comes with that,
which is you don't get to blame society
for your problems.
This is why the.
I think that the Bernie Sanders
argument,
the Hillary Clinton argument is wrong.
You know,
Bernie Sanders,
he's ever,
ever other tweet from Bernie Sanders is
something like we live in a world where
there's,
where there's massive income inequality
and we need to do something about that.
And I think to myself,
well,
that's called a world of reality.
I mean,
every society in history has had income
inequality,
including communist ones.
And you're not showing me a villain,
right?
You're saying reality is bad.
Blame Society for all the problems.
Show me an actual villain and I'm happy
to fight them.
Show me some,
some ghost villain.
And I can't fight goes,
I just can't.
Right.
So when you hear that stuff though,
do you acknowledge at some level that
there's some level of crony capitalism
that keeps making the big companies
bigger and crushing all of the small
companies and I still think he's
striking to that point,
but I guess he's not doing it in a
really direct.
Right?
If you were attacking crony capitalism,
he and the tea party on the same page.
The problem with with the occupy Wall
Street movement,
which was supposedly ripping crony
capitalism,
is they were saying crony capitalism is
bad.
Therefore the government should pick
more companies to help or it should
nationalized companies outright,
which is not the solution,
right?
If you used a crony capitalism is
capitalism is bad.
First of all,
I don't like the term crony capitalism
because it's not capitalism.
It's corporatism,
right?
Capitalism is not being.
Being a,
a person who operates in business does
not make you a capitalist business.
People take loans and subsidies from the
government all the time.
That's right.
Capitalist thing to do.
Right?
So it's,
it's a,
it's a self interested thing to do,
but self interest in capitalism are not
identical.
Yeah.
If you wanted to actually fight crony
capitalism,
then cut off the tie between government
and the private sector completely.
Which I would certainly prefer,
and this is part of the Republican Party
that I dislike.
I think there's a certainly corporate
trust side of the establishment,
Republican Party that is very much in
favor of government involvement in the
economy and I don't like that in the
slightest,
but that's not Bernie's real critique
if,
if could,
because if it were a full of free market
system,
if the government weren't reaching out
to people,
and by the way the government,
if you're going to argue against crony
capitalism,
you also have to argue against
government subsidized loans for people
who can't afford them for houses,
right?
Which causes massive economic crashes,
which Bernie apparently doesn't oppose.
Redman.
He would like more of those things.
You would like all of us to subsidize
bad.
You know that folks,
bad credit taking out loans.
If you actually,
if you got rid of all those things,
if you got rid of government
involvement,
Bernie Sanders would still think that
something was wrong.
If Bill Gates is earning a lot of money
and somebody the bottom is earning none,
he see somebody in a room with $5 in
somebody with one and he immediately
says the guy with $5 must've stolen
something from the guy with $1.
Whereas I say,
I have no evidence of that until you
show me that evidence may be the guy
with $5 produced more than the guy with
$1.
So I'll follow you up that line of
thinking.
So then we're,
where do we get to a point where it
seems like to me at some level there
should be some sort of progressive tax.
It shouldn't be necessarily.
You know,
when they talked about the one percent,
the studies were sort of all over the
place,
but it sounds like if you were in about
400 grand a year,
you're in,
you're in the one percent.
I'm not in the one percent I am.
You're in the one percent.
I agree.
All right,
well good.
I bet it took me a long time.
They got some money.
No,
that's why I'm in the one percent
present that had to take care of their
money,
but okay.
So either way I'm proud of that fact.
I'm not gonna.
Act like everybody asks ashamed about
how much money they earn in this
country.
I think this is the only thing that's
charming about Donald Trump is that I
think that you should be proud of how
much money you earned in this country
because if you worked to get there,
I mean I spent a lot of money to go to
law school and then I spent a lot of
times slogging in the trenches and now I
make a really good living and I work a
lot of hours to make that really good
living and my wife,
you know,
we had to pay her entire medical
education out of pocket and she's gonna
be a doctor and she's going to make a
really good living.
Good for her.
Good for me.
Good for good.
For anybody who earns a living in this
country.
That's it.
That's a good thing,
but as far as the progressive tax,
no,
I think the progressive tax,
a bunch of crap.
I think I know.
What about at some point,
so you get to $10,000,000
a year that it could be progressively,
you know,
you just don't believe in that.
No,
because I don't see why you deserve a
bigger percentage of my money because I
make more money.
The all taxes are is a is a gangster
shakedown and so when,
when and that's all they are.
And so we can all agree that some
gangster shakedowns are worthwhile
because we have to pay for police,
but the idea that here's the problem
with any sort of progressive tax.
There are three,
and this is just the general problem
with progressive taxation.
You have three people in a room,
two of them are not bill gates in.
One of them is they vote two to one,
that they should take half of Bill Gates
as well.
Okay.
This is a simplified version of American
politics.
Yeah.
Here's my basic rule for all legislation
and all taxation.
If you pass this law,
are you willing to shoot the person who
disobeys because that's what the
government is.
The government is just a big shooting
people machine,
right?
That's what the government does.
The install in,
whether you're talking national defense
or the police,
there's certain laws or you pass them
and you say,
if you just obey this law and if you
resist me with a gun,
I'm willing to shoot you.
So what laws are you willing to shoot
somebody over?
This seems to be a pretty good measure
of am I?
Well,
so for example,
so for taxation.
Yes.
So the question is,
are you willing to shoot people who
don't pay taxes?
If those taxes go for the national
defense,
the Ta that protects us all.
The answer is yes.
Because if nobody pays that tax,
then presumably everybody dies in some
sort of terrorist attack.
But if you're going to ask me,
you know,
are you willing to pay a progressive tax
for whatever stupid government bowl
they're pushing today?
And am I willing to shoot somebody over
that?
No,
I think the purpose of the tax is just
as important as the percentage.
So is that really the problem that we
have no idea at this point where our
money goes?
Absolutely.
We just don't.
Even now I'm hearing,
you know,
Bernie will say I'm ready.
You know,
he talked to that guy at the town hall
and the Guy said,
I earned $41,000
a year in Bernie admitted your taxes
will go up,
and then he explains,
well,
the health costs are going to go down or
whatever.
That may or may not make no sense.
He says,
I'm going to tax you $5,000.
You're going to get $10,000
back in medical service.
What magic,
what magical box did you make that
happen and is there.
Are there doctors in the back room
there?
When he said that,
I was thinking,
well,
if you're healthy,
if the government that say I wish left
to solutions work because they're the
easiest solutions in the world,
right?
It's a recession tax.
Everybody at 100 percent redistribute
the wealth in tomb days.
The recessions over there,
they're crap by the way.
They're also a moral,
you know,
the left,
the left talks about these things as
though it's moral,
it's not moral to steal other people's
wealth just because you're poorer than
they are.
All right,
so let's dive in to the left.
So as I told you before we started and I
hinted at here,
so I came from the progressive world.
I've been,
I now view being progressive basically
as a mental disorder or something,
but I consider myself classic liberal,
which really,
really is conservative in a lot of
respects.
It's libertarian essentially.
Yeah.
It's technically defined.
It's conservative or libertarian as I'm
somewhere in there.
Um,
and it seems to me that the Republicans,
if they would stick with what are
supposed to be there principles that you
were talking about,
they would have a much better argument
than what they have right now.
And that they don't stick to their
argument.
That's part of the problem.
Well,
I think that what's happened is
government has gotten larger.
It turns into this giant grab bag of
cash.
And so what you have is a bunch of
constituencies in the United States who
are dependent on these.
Grab bags of cash.
I remember I was,
I was down in Palm Beach,
Florida for a,
for conferences,
must've been five years ago.
And uh,
and Linda lingle who was then running
for Senate in Hawaii,
uh,
was former governor of why Republican,
she was,
she was speaking at a,
at a synagogue and I was there and this
little old lady,
Palm Beach,
a very rich area,
this little old lady titles up to her
Pearl Necklace,
diamond earrings,
and she walks up and says,
what will you do to keep them from
cutting my social security?
And I thought to myself,
who are you like you paid $50 into
social security when you were 35 and
you're probably getting out $3,000
a month now.
But because people have been made that
promise,
they're now dependent on the government.
So what do Republicans do?
Republicans say,
no,
no.
I would never do away with social
security,
right?
We would transition it or we would save
it.
Once you get into the business of the
government takes care of you and your
old age.
Now we're just arguing over methodology.
We're not arguing over morality.
My view is that people have been made
promises.
We have to keep those promises because
otherwise we just have too many people
who have no source of income.
You make a promise,
you keep a promise,
but if you are under a particular age,
no social security at all.
Take.
I want my money back.
Okay.
I'm getting 15 percent of my salary
taken every year to be put in a fund
that I will never see again.
Again,
I have.
I have one child and I have another one
on the way.
I would much prefer to put that in a Sep
Ira and just let that grow with the
stock market.
By the way,
you want stock market,
the boom,
take all the money out of social
security and put it into companies on
the stock market.
You want to see an actual economic
growth curve that would do it as opposed
to pretending that it's in a lock box
somewhere that doesn't exist when
they're just rating it every two days
for
the lockbox never existed.
Never.
Gore said he had the lockbox.
There was nobody.
There was no lock box.
It's,
it's a Ponzi scheme.
All right,
so to the left though,
because I'm with you,
I'm with you on that,
that they're not.
They're sort of just not holding to
their principles.
So what I've seen in the left is that
most people went from being liberal and
then somehow over the last couple of
years they've become these social
justice warriors and they've divided
everybody by what all our differences,
our skin color and religion and all
that,
and they've picked a pecking order of
who's the most aggrieved and that the
victim is hierarchy,
the victim hierarchy.
And because of this,
uh,
it seems to me that it's just,
there's no end to it,
that that's what scares me the most
about the ideology is there simply is no
end game with it because ultimately it
has to eat itself because then one day
you'll fight for everybody else and then
they'll come around and they'll come
back.
I mean,
is what's happening on college campuses.
College campuses are about as left as
it's possible to be,
except that the leftists are now eating
their own right.
They're going to the administrators and
saying,
you're all microaggressing us and we
need trigger warnings and it's white
privilege,
and they're ousting people who who were
protesting in these buildings 40 years
ago on the left,
and they're.
They're getting them fired now.
I mean,
Larry Lawrence Summers was,
was Clinton Secretary of the treasury.
I was at Harvard when they throw them
out,
right,
and they throw him out because he made
the politically incorrect statement that
maybe there weren't that many women in
the high reaches of science because
women didn't want to be in the higher
reaches of science or it's possible
there weren't enough women who are
qualified for that and they throw him
out for that.
I mean,
the.
What's happened I think,
is that we've reached a point where the
wealthiest society in the history of the
world,
the people here are the wealthiest that
any people have ever been,
and we've also forgotten that there's a.
If there's any sort of ideological
existential threat.
I was four when the Soviet Union
collapsed,
so people my age and younger don't
remember the Soviet Union.
They don't.
They don't recall it.
It's not important to their lives and
when they think of socialism,
they think of kind of the happy dappy
socialism of Denmark.
They never look at the tax rates,
but they think,
okay,
everything is going okay in Denmark.
They forget,
forget the fact that we've paid for
Denmark's national security for the last
half century.
Forget the fact that they're now having
to cut their taxes.
Forget the fact they just elected a
government to keep out the Islamic wave
that's now swamping and all those things
go by the wayside.
So what happens is that all these people
kind of live off the fat of the land we
all do and then rip away at the
foundations because when you're living
in such a rich society and you look at,
for example,
income inequality and you said there's
some people who are earning millions of
dollars and there are some people who
are earning tens of thousands of
dollars.
What we forget is that in human history
and in human society,
the difference there,
there's literally millions of dollars
and tens and tens of thousands of
dollars and then there's where people
have been historically which is here,
right?
And when you rip away the foundation's,
everybody's going to end up down here.
You can't just take all of the founding
principles of small government and free
markets and rip them away.
But what's happened is when young people
are always looking for a reason to
fight,
I mean we,
we want to change the world.
That's our thing.
Changing the world.
One of the world's pretty good.
What do you change?
We've basically changed a lot of the
external circumstances and now the
question is,
you're rich.
You live a pretty free life,
right?
So what's wrong?
Only what I feel is wrong,
what's in here is what's wrong,
and so it's become very feelings based
society.
Anything that said to me that hurts my
feelings is now no longer just something
hurtful.
It's a microaggression,
right?
And I can actually reach out and I can
harm you.
I can.
I can ban you.
I can call the police if you hurt my
feelings at University of Missouri.
There was actually when,
when this whole thing was going down,
there was there,
the University of Missouri Police
Department put out a notice.
If somebody says something to you that's
racist,
call the police department,
right?
Seventy percent.
There was a poll that just came out that
70 percent of college students are
comfortable with hate speech codes on
campus.
Forty percent of college,
student of millennials,
people aged 18 to 34,
40 percent of them believe that speech
that's offensive to women or minorities
should be banned in the United States
across.
So some of this though that young people
are just kind of dumb,
like the world is going to teach you
some stuff and when you're at college
you're going to be kind of dumb.
I had a guest on a couple of weeks ago,
Michael Shermer,
who said that they're all this
microaggression stuff and all of this
free speech,
as horrible as it sounds to us,
right?
He sort of was arguing that in a way you
could say,
this shows the progress because instead
of having to fight for actual things,
they're fighting for these feelings and
not that he was for.
That shows you that we've progressed and
that you know that black people aren't
fighting so that they have separate
water fountains.
They are now fighting over things that
may,
that are just about feelings and that's
obviously
awesome and you're right.
It's testament to the progress,
but I mean ted,
to golf,
what you were saying,
50 years ago,
black people were fighting to not have
separate water fountains and today
they're fighting to have separate water
fountains,
right?
I mean they actually want separate black
housing at USC.
They actually wanted a separate black
safe space at University of Missouri.
This is dangerous stuff and what's more
dangerous is an entire political
hierarchy.
The benefits from this because now
you've got candidates who benefit by
telling particular interest groups and
racial groups.
You're a victim.
We're going to help you out.
The way we are going to help you out is
by specifically calling the rest of the
society racist.
You're a victim forever and the longer
we can make you feel like you're a
victim,
the more you're dependent on us.
Right?
Well,
what?
We'll just go.
I mean,
Hillary Clinton was doing this in in
Harlem the other day.
She was saying,
yeah,
we haven't cured racism in the country
and that's why I'm going to take
hundreds of millions of dollars poured
into Harlem is though nobody's poured
hundreds of millions of dollars into
Harlem before the only dollars into
Harlem that are actually going to matter
are police dollars to clean up high
crime areas so that investors will go in
and the reason that businesses aren't
going into high crime areas is because
they're high crime areas and just
dumping money in there and get help.
So you would agree that racism exists.
Of course there are people that are
legitimate reasons.
It would be idiotic to think otherwise.
Of course there are legitimate racist
and we should target them and we should
find them and we should hurt their
careers because racism is unacceptable.
But what I don't agree with is this.
I don't like fighting phantoms.
As I said earlier.
Institutional racism is a meaningless
phrase.
Libraries are not racist.
Schools are not racist.
You have to show me a law,
a policy,
a person who is racist.
You can't just say American society is
racist because that doesn't mean
anything.
Show me the actual problem that we can
discuss because when you just throw
tautologies out there like that,
what am I supposed to do?
I mean there's no way to fight that.
There's legitimately no way to fight it.
That's right.
So I discussed that with Larry elder
who's conservative,
but on the,
on the libertarian side,
and he basically said what you just
said,
and I think some of my progressive
friends would say,
well,
it may not be institutional anymore and
that there are laws that existed,
no longer exists,
but they would say,
well,
a certain communities will get less
because of racism just because of the
idea of racism will get less qualified
people to teach and that they will be
treated differently by the police and
all of that.
Well,
by by income level,
that's true,
but it's true.
By income level,
it's not a race and income level tend to
correlate.
Unfortunately,
but that's,
that's more to do with income level than
it has to do with race.
It's not like there's somebody sitting
in Sacramento today in California
growing up black community.
We're not putting anybody in there.
I mean the real,
the real gap in the country,
especially between rich and poor is two
parent households,
not race.
I mean the poverty rate in the black
community for two parent households is
seven percent.
The poverty rate in the white community
for,
for a single parent household is 22
percent.
So Larry said that to middle,
so that same thing and he got a lot of
hate for it and then I got lumped into
the because people.
So I'll just go with you on that for,
for the purposes just so I'll trust that
you're giving me a fair statistics
statistics.
So fair enough,
but that,
that enrages people.
There's something about that concept I
think that really upsets people and you
would say that that's really because of
the feeling.
Well,
yeah,
this is my catchphrase goes facts don't
care about your feelings.
I mean there were.
The reality is,
yeah,
exactly.
This is as,
as we move forward and American society,
the only thing that's going to cure the
ills that we have is looking at some of
the real problems straight in the face.
I mean,
the fact is that when welfare was
instituted in the sixties before it was
instituted,
the black single motherhood rate was 20
percent.
That is now in excess of 70 percent and
it's not just.
It's not just impacting the black
community.
It's impacting the white community.
Right?
The white community used to have a five
percent single motherhood.
Right now it's in excess of 40 percent.
The fact is you are going to get higher
crime,
you're going to get more poverty.
It's the Brookings Institute,
which is a left institute,
right?
I mean,
so it's a liberal institute at the
Brookings Institute and they kind of
straddle that line between liberal left.
They say that if you don't want to be
permanently poor in the United States,
you need to do three things and three
things.
Only graduate high school,
get a job in hold it.
Don't have a baby before you're married.
That's it.
And by the way,
those things have nothing to do with
racism,
right?
There's not a white person there.
Let's.
They're very fee.
I would be hard pressed to find a black
person in America,
almost straw man yourself there,
right?
I,
I'd be hard pressed to.
Maybe there's one.
I don't know how many single black
single mothers got pregnant because a
white man was holding a gun to a black
man's head and said,
I want you to impregnate this person.
Then leave.
Okay.
Be Single.
Motherhood is a decision that's made by
the people who are involved in the
sexual act and what happens afterward.
And it's the single best predictor of,
of gender,
intergenerational poverty.
So make good decisions.
So,
so is really the issue that when the
left doesn't deal with these things,
honestly,
that then they're just handing it to the
right.
I mean,
I see this,
we've been talking about this a lot
related to all this stuff with Islam,
Islam that because the left calls
everyone a racist.
So anytime me or any of my friends that
are talking about this,
there's not many of us on the left.
Every time we bring it up,
I mean I'm getting called a big left and
right and now and yet they can't say,
well,
can you point to something bigoted I've
said or something racist and they can't,
but it's a feeling.
Feel offended.
They feel offended.
But is this where if the left doesn't
deal with something?
So you know,
you can talk about Islam is or if the
deaf,
if the left doesn't deal with the roots
of income inequality as you've laid out
that you just hand it to the far right
ultimately,
right?
I mean,
doesn't this sort of explained trump to
you?
Well,
to,
to a certain extent,
I think that that's right.
I think that what happens is that there
is a,
in A.
I would never justify people reacting
and racist fashion because you know,
you can react in a reasonable fashion to
stupidity.
People say silly things like single
motherhood doesn't matter.
And I say no single motherhood
absolutely does matter,
but what people tend to what some,
a certain segment of the population,
and this is true both on the left and
the right,
is when they,
when,
when somebody says something they don't
like,
they immediately go to racism.
I mean,
I can't tell you the number of tweets I
have received after,
after I said that I don't like Donald
Trump.
That's when the antisemites come out of
the woodwork and it's in.
It's bizarre to me.
Like it's,
it's like what is,
what is my Jewishness have to do with
not liking trump?
And as far as I'm aware of his daughters
natural convert to Judaism.
So it's,
it's,
it's weird,
but it's.
But um,
yeah,
and I think that it's,
it's polarizing the debate in a way that
need not.
We're not,
we're not trying to solve problems
anymore in American politics.
I'll,
we're trying to do is demonize the other
side and turn them into the bad guy.
And so my goal is to demonize the people
who try to demonize,
right?
The,
the,
those are the people who ought to be
demonized.
If,
if your goal in politics is to make
character attacks without regard to
facts,
then I'm not interested in,
in debating you on on facts because
you're clearly not interested in
debating on fact.
Yeah,
so that's a.
that's a good segue because I read your
11 rules for debating leftists and I
just read.
I read the entire thing this morning.
Okay.
That's pretty good.
It's pretty short,
but it's on my mind and basically
everything you said.
I was struggling when I was reading
because I was like,
oh,
I'm agreeing with all of this because I
still consider myself liberal and there
is a part of me that I don't want to
read something by a guy that's
conservative and go,
I agree with this stuff,
but a lot of what I saw in there are the
exact tactics that I've seen this
regressive left use on me and use on Sam
Harris and all these other relentlessly.
So you really gave the antidote to some
of these things so you don't have to lay
out all 11,
but you want to pick some highlights
because I think there's some really.
Yeah,
I mean a lot of them kind of turn into,
okay,
so I'm trying to remember all 11 off the
top of my head or at least give me a
couple.
So.
So the.
The first one is that you have to
embrace the fight.
You have to understand going in that
you're in a fight,
usually any you have to sort of
determine the purpose of the
conversation that you're having is just
base and this is true if you're left or
right,
actually determine what your goal is.
Is your goal to convince the person on
the other side,
is the person open to being convinced?
If not,
you're wasting your time.
Are you on a show and there's an
audience,
in which case you're not speaking to the
person you're speaking to the audience,
and once you determine that,
understand that,
that if there's hostility,
you have to be ready to punch back twice
as hard.
You have to and be preemptive in that
attack,
which by the way you say that's a left
idea.
These are all left ideas.
These punch back twice as hard.
I mean,
it was President Obama who coined the
phrase,
right.
He was the one who was saying that his
supporters Audit Punch back twice as
hard and I've sort of hijack dad because
I think that it's actually an effective
tactic and necessary.
I've also said that one of that is
important at the very outset to ensure
that the framing of questions is proper
because one of the ways that the left is
succeeds and you see it in the
Republican debates particularly is
they'll ask a question and then the
Republicans won't even bother to try
reframing what the question is.
So John Dickerson,
the other night and in the CBS debate,
he opens up with any tries to brow beat
Ted Cruz on.
You say that nobody should be confirmed
in the last year of a presidents have a
presidents run.
Isn't it true that the constitution says
the president gets to pick the nominee
and Cruz instead of just saying,
John,
I don't care about the timeline.
I don't know what you're talking about.
We're not going to confirm anybody who
doesn't agree with Scalia.
Right?
Instead of just saying that,
and it's not our obligation to do that,
the constitution has many provisions.
John,
you know,
instead of just reframing the question,
he sort of bought into it and you and
you see that from a lot of these,
from a lot of Republicans,
they just accept the question as it
comes to them rather than thinking
there's,
there's a second question that's usually
kind of embedded in the first question
that's being asked in most in most
debate.
So those are a couple examples.
There's also,
you don't have to accept the,
uh,
you don't have to accept the kind of
hero worship the that so many
Republicans do.
One of the frequent ones that you do is
somebody will say,
well,
Ronald Reagan was for amnesty.
Why do I care?
I was,
I was too.
When,
when,
when you did amnesty and what it will
look like.
You want to talk about regular or limb.
When people try to misdirect to Bush,
you know,
they don't,
like you were saying something about
Obama.
So they say something about Bush.
So a proper answer should be FDR,
Woodrow Wilson,
William Howard Taft.
Like,
well,
you want to talk about Bush,
we'll talk about Bush Obama,
we'll talk about Obama,
like let's stick to the topic at hand.
So a lot of my basic rules for debate
can basically be boiled down to two,
two,
which is get the character assassination
off the table if they were going to call
you a racist,
sexist,
bigot,
homophobe.
The proper response is not,
no,
I'm not a racist,
sexist,
bigot,
homophobe.
Here's all the proof that I'm,
it's no,
you're a jackass because you have no
proof of calling me that and accusing
people of things without evidence is the
mark of being a jackass.
Right?
And that's that.
That is the proper response.
And then once that's all off the table,
then we can actually have a policy
argument.
So what do you do about people that
don't stop doing that?
I,
I had some leave and I just let it be.
You leave.
I mean you say this is not a worthwhile
debate.
You're an asshole and I'm leaving.
There's,
there's no,
there's no purpose to it.
Think not picking up the fight.
And this would be whether you're on the
left or the right,
whatever,
whatever fight you're in that sometimes
by not picking up the fight,
you actually are strengthening them.
No,
I mean,
because I think you're strengthening
here.
Here's the logic,
right?
If somebody calls me a racist and you
say,
no,
let me explain to you why I'm not a
racist.
You what you're really saying,
what you're really saying is you're
irrational fellow.
Let's have a conversation about why I'm
not a racist by even granting the
predicate,
your rational fellow,
he just called you a racist,
right?
If you say to me,
I'm a racist,
and then I say,
well,
you're a rational thought.
Well,
I'm saying to you,
you're right.
I'm a racist.
You're rational fellow calling me a
racist.
A rational person could theoretically
think I'm a racist.
No,
the answer is that's an irrational
thought.
You're being irrational.
What you're saying is,
is ridiculous,
and you're a bad person for dropping
charges on me without evidence.
Only bad people do this,
right?
If you're going to drop a charge,
make sure he can back it up.
Well,
that's the thing,
I find that there's an incredible lack
of being able to back it up and there's
a constant,
I don't know that you address this
specifically,
but I find it a lot of these debates
when I had these debates with people,
there's a constant moving of the goal
post,
so you say something and you sort of get
the point across and they they can even
if they don't outwardly accept that it
is being intellectually do and then they
just move what they say and then they
just keep moving and moving it and then
you're,
you know,
you're back in Sir Circle.
I do say in that pamphlet that arguing
with people on the left is sort of like
trying to nail Jello to the wall.
The minute,
the minute that you finished one
argument,
they're already onto the next and
they're usually swiveling to places the
demo comfortable like same sex marriage
or social issues because that,
that,
those are,
those are issues closer to the heart so
they're,
they're more comfortable for them to
argue.
And so if you're arguing economics,
invariably you find yourself talking
about why Republicans are mean to gay
people or something.
It's always a shifting goalposts because
you can't get an if they.
If the left.
This is what I like about sanders.
I think sanders will actually give
honest answers to questions.
If I say to Bernie Sanders,
Bernie,
what constitutes income equality?
Forgetting income inequality?
Like what gradation would it be?
Income equality.
Does everybody have to earn the same?
Because there's a name for that,
right?
I mean if everybody earns the same,
the only way to do that is to confiscate
all wealth and redistribute it.
That's called Communism,
right?
I think that sanders would,
would actually answer that,
but most people on the left won't.
They'll just move the goal posts.
And what do you think you would actually
say?
I think that would,
he would probably say is you would say
the sort of income inequality that we
see in Europe is,
is,
is more beneficial to the,
to the United States.
And you say,
well,
okay,
that requires a 60 percent tax rate.
It means that the car,
literally the prices of your car will
double because they have massive excise
taxes over in Denmark and you know if,
if that's something that you want to do,
you're also going to have to raise taxes
on the poor,
raised taxes on the middle class.
You're going to have to gauge the fact
that every in America is going to leave,
which is not going to be pleasant for
you.
Are you willing to.
Are you willing to build?
Here's the thing about Bernie Sanders,
his economic policy.
Donald trump wants to build a wall to
keep people out.
Bernie Sanders will have to build a wall
to keep businesses in because they will
leave.
They actually have to chain them to a
stake in order to keep them here.
All right,
so we've talked about a lot of stuff
that we sort of agree on.
I haven't agreed with everything,
but I'm letting you talk.
People always yell at me.
They say,
you don't.
You don't yell back at your,
well let's,
let's do it.
Let's do this by.
So let's,
let's get into some other stuff.
So the gay marriage,
let's talk to a marriage or you're not
big on gay marriage?
No,
I'm not at a.
not on a social level.
I think the government ought to be
completely out of the business of
marriage.
I think the government sucks at
everything is my.
Is My short message for today.
The government is terrible at
everything.
If the government's goal is to forward
traditional marriage,
utterly failed obviously.
As you don't mind to being out of the
business of traditional marriage at all.
No,
I think that.
I think the government should be out of
all marriage.
I think the government stinks at this,
you know,
now I will say that.
Do I think that the.
I think the idea of the government
subsidizing gay marriage is silly
because I don't think that there's
societal benefit to gay marriage.
If you're going to make the argument
that government should be involved in
marriage at all,
just not even an argument with which I
agree at this point the way it is right
now.
Let's go from that.
Okay.
So before I get there,
one quick point.
The reason I want the government out of
the business of marriage is because now
that the government has enshrined gay
marriage,
the next step is going to be going to
religious people and telling them they
have to engage with same sex weddings.
So as a religious person,
this is problematic to me.
I want a society in which I can do what
I want and I don't have to care what you
think and you can do what you want and
you don't have to cover it.
I think it doesn't mean you get to come
into my synagogue and get married.
It also doesn't mean that I have to go
to your gay wedding.
That's an interesting place to have the
discussion because I would argue for gay
marriage for the exact reasons.
I don't want the government involved in
all of these things.
Right,
and that's exactly why gay marriage
should exist and I think it ran Paul.
It hit that point harder.
It would have made a sensible
libertarian argument of limited
government and you know what,
dude?
Go ahead and you want to smoke weed on
you and your bright.
Well,
I tend to agree with both of those
things.
I agree with,
and by the way,
I find people who smoke weed,
unbelievably irritating,
but that's not my business.
I mean,
this is the beauty of America is you
don't have to give a crap what I think
we said this is what you end the show by
taking the bong hit.
Oh yeah.
Well that's going to be awkward then.
But,
but the uh,
the,
the uh,
as far as the secondary argument about
let's,
let's take the predicate that government
is now involved in marriage.
Should government subsidized gay
marriage and straight marriage the same
way?
My answer is no,
because the only purpose for the
government getting involved in marriage
is the procreation of the next
generation and the raising of that
generation.
And it's my belief that a man and a
woman to a better job of raising a child
and producing children,
obviously biologically than two men or
two women.
What is it isn't the child.
Part of it is sort of secondary.
I mean,
there are plenty of people that get
married,
gay couples and straight couples that
don't have kids.
There's a siren in and of itself is in
just about,
but at a governmental level,
I don't care about those people are
meaning like I care that I'm happy that
they're happy,
but I don't,
I don't really care what they do.
Like it didn't,
it doesn't.
The government theoretically has an
interest in the production of the next
generation,
right?
That's the only interest in marriage.
So in fact,
you could even make a case to government
ought to be giving,
you know,
basically tax benefits for,
for having kids,
um,
and no benefit for marriage,
right?
But,
but the truth is,
the reason that this was created in the
first place obviously is because before
the advent of,
I mean,
long before the advent of modern birth
control,
the,
the fair assumption was that if you were
having sex,
then you are going to get pregnant,
right?
At least if you were having straight
sex,
you're going to have pregnant,
you were going to get pregnant.
And thus we wanted to incentivize people
to stick around for that because single
motherhood is bad for the community.
And so we're going to subsidize that
with tax benefits.
By the way,
there is no,
there is no marriage benefit.
There's a marriage penalty.
My wife and I pay a significantly higher
tax rate because we have a combined
income.
Right?
So you're not against still despite
coming from some sort of.
It's not a religious art,
religious art.
That's what I want to distinguish
because of court,
because we should be for a separation of
church and state.
And I think you are for separation
truths.
So the separation of church and state
means that I just want to make a quick
distinction or separation of church and
state doesn't mean that I can't bring my
religious values to bear and how I vote.
It just means that I can't leverage
Jewish ritual on you.
There's no establishment of Jewish
religion,
Christian religion.
But I should be able to make a secular
argument for why what I'm saying is
right is my general rule because
otherwise we're operating in different
spheres.
If I cite the Bible,
it makes no difference to you.
You don't care about the Bible.
So.
Right.
So I'm,
I'm a secular Jew.
I would consider,
I mean I'm an atheist so it doesn't.
Judaism is ethnic and irrelevant every
other respect.
I like her.
You like her?
Who Curb your enthusiasm?
Oh,
well,
hey,
I mean that's cultural Judaism like
bagels and Matzah balls and I don't
care,
you know,
I feel pretty good it.
Okay.
Okay,
so let's not get hung up with that,
but you're making the distinction
between.
This isn't coming from a religious place
now.
I think part of the problem when it
comes to gay marriage is that a huge
portion of the Christian right is trying
to impose their religious values on
this.
So it itself isn't religious,
but the Po know the rationale for the
policy can.
This is one where I'm making the
distinction.
The rationale for people voting can
still be religious,
but if the policy is not religious,
if there's a secular rationality is what
Scalia said about it actually,
if there's a secular rationale to it
than the motivations of the voters don't
matter.
Like I don't care what the motivation of
the voter is in virtually any
circumstance,
I matter what the vote is.
Right?
And if somebody wants to vote for lower
taxes,
I don't care whether they're doing it
because they're on principle for lower
taxes or whether they personally want
lower taxes on their income.
I just care about the outcome of the
vote,
the outcome with a boat.
Okay.
So basically you don't care about gay
marriage as the contract ends right now,
you simply don't care.
You're one concern though,
is that ultimately this will lead to the
government forcing gay marriage on
synagogues that don't want to have it,
or mosques that don't want to.
Not Ultimately.
Like now in California,
they've already passed laws that you
have to teach.
Same sex marriage in public schools for
example.
Like it changes the nature of the
teaching.
My view on that is,
I don't know why the.
I went to public school for elementary
and junior high.
I don't understand why the government is
teaching me anything about this stuff.
This is for my parents to teach me like
this.
This is a values thing.
So I guess that's sort of where it's
just values just get completed with what
we're taught like well as sort of a to
know.
I mean there are no values to math right
there no valid Matthew Bright,
but there are no values to biology
there.
Their,
their values to history,
which is why it's dicey and it's.
And it's disingenuous what the left has
done with the education system.
There are multiple perspectives on
history and the monopolistic takeover of
the liberal arts is a real problem and
you can have multiple perspectives on
that.
But we're not teaching marriage in the
context of history or English.
We're teaching in the context of science
which has nothing to do with anything.
So when again,
you a PC comes in.
I mean when I was,
when,
when they're doing sex ed,
when I was in junior high,
they're making a big deal out of the
idea that everybody,
you know,
everybody is equally likely due to get
aids for example.
Not True.
I mean it's just not true,
but it aids is a behavioral driven
disease or if you don't,
I will never get aids.
Right.
Barring a barring a blood transfusion
that that has aids,
I don't,
I don't do an intravenous drugs and I
don't have promiscuous sex and I was a
virgin when I married my wife and she
was a virgin when she married me.
So we're,
so we're,
we're safe,
right?
We're,
we're,
we're good.
We're about to save as you can get on
this and so.
So I don't like the,
the again,
the facts being trumped by what we
wished the facts were so that we can
push certain political agendas.
Right.
So how do you then taking this argument
from a secular place?
How do you then feel being in the same
party that have so many people that are
taking it from a right wing Christian
place?
Because there isn't there.
There's a seemingly odd alliance there
that I think is a.
I agree with them on the end point.
I even agree with them religiously.
I just don't think they're good
spokespeople for their cars.
I mean,
I think that if you,
if you,
if you are,
if you're a chief citation to your
opposition to gay marriage,
is leviticus 18,
22?
I don't think that that's a solid
argument that's going to convince a lot
of people.
Right?
Uh,
I think that,
you know,
there are better arguments against gay
marriage than that.
Right?
Um,
and so,
you know,
this is something I talk about at
religious schools and I've been asked by
pastors and rabbis and priests to talk
to students about,
okay,
you have these religious principles.
Is there any justification outside of
the Bible says,
so for why this is correct.
And as a religious person who actually
thought through his positions,
I tend to believe there is,
like I see it as a religious person.
I believe that God didn't create stupid
rules.
So if you believe that God didn't create
stupid rules,
then you have to come up with some sort
of justification for the rules that are
being expressed.
Like there's something you can
understand that just an article of
faith,
but,
but the,
the,
the big ones about human behavior,
there should be a decent rationale.
You can explain to people who don't buy
into revelation.
Sure.
So there I would just say,
well,
you're basing your belief in God.
It's just a belief,
not anything that can be proven,
so relative.
So no,
no,
but anyone that's basing anything on
religion is just based on some unproven
thing that is,
I would say I want that nothing to do
with my life
that which is,
which is fine and that's why we live in
America.
Good.
Yeah,
but,
but I will say this,
every belief system is based on
something unproven.
All of them.
Human rights means nothing.
Where do you get that?
Your basis of human rights
from a feeling.
How about that?
Exactly.
I just get you to subjective.
Well,
right.
But that's a,
that's a blend.
So you're saying basically where the
liberals would say,
I'm for this because I'm for gay people.
I want gay people to be able to do what
want to do and
pursue happiness.
Like anyone else you would say,
well this has nothing to do with
government and whatever.
So I can't.
There's not a lot of.
Not a lot of conflict here.
Yeah.
My governmental policy,
because I'm basically a libertarian is,
is I don't care about that.
Again,
the government,
what do we strengthen that group of
people so clearly we don't agree quite
agree on this thing,
but I understand your rationale and
you're not trying to stop gay people
from getting married.
I think right now,
I think right now the next conflict is
not going to come from the right.
It's going to come from the left pushing
the ball,
meaning that it's going to come from the
case in Oregon with this Baker who,
who,
you know,
doesn't want to service a same sex
wedding,
doesn't want to actually have to cater
it.
Uh,
as uh,
you know,
I think that good hearted people should
say,
fine,
you do what you want.
Go across the street to the bakery.
Like,
okay,
that's what I would say.
And this is the difference,
you know,
liberal and leftist in a nutshell,
this is the difference between liberal
and leftist.
Liberal says your business,
I don't care.
I left.
It says,
no,
no.
I think it's imperative that you will be
made to care.
Right?
And Erik Erickson's phrase,
you'll be made to care.
Somebody is going to,
a man will come to your house with a gun
and he will tell you that if you do not
cater this wedding,
this is what they were forced by a
hundred $75,000,
fine for not catering,
lesbian wedding or there's a bakery
across the street,
you know this is,
this is really an a farrier stuff,
so this is where you're asking where the
momentum comes from.
This is where the momentum comes from.
So when I make an argument to
conservatives and religious people that
the government ought to get out of the
business and marriage.
I'm not saying that because I'm pro gay
marriage,
very much anti gay marriage in the
social sense.
I don't think that that,
you know,
as as a religious person,
I think homosexuality is a sin.
I think lots of things are sentenced
that people engage in.
I think they should be free to engage in
them,
but as a religious person,
that's not.
That's not my thing.
I don't think that gay marriage is a
great,
massively good thing for society on a
social level,
but on a governmental level,
if you guys don't just get out of this
business entirely,
the left has no end point.
They're only endpoint is using the
government as a club against you.
So now that they've got gay marriage,
it will go to,
it will go to.
We're going to stop accrediting schools
that don't teach gay marriage or higher
homosexual employees.
Right?
And you've got Catholic churches say,
I don't want to pay the health benefits
of somebody gay partner that's a
Catholic church.
Why should it have to write?
But the left would say,
no,
they have to be.
You will be made to care.
This is why you're a bad person if you
don't do this.
And so if so,
what am I arguments?
The rightest sensible liberal.
Right?
Exactly.
So this is.
But,
but this way you'd actually get heavy
argument from the not so sensible
liberals probably including all of the
democratic nominees.
The the fact is that what I'm saying is
the best argument for the Libertarian
position on the right here is gonna be a
rear guard action.
It's not going to be.
It's better for straight people be in.
It's bad for gay marriage to get it out
of that realm.
It's I think that if you want to fight
against gay marriage,
do it on the social level with your
church,
teach your kids what you want to teach
them,
but when it comes to,
when it comes to making this argument to
conservatives,
the real argument is if you don't take
power out of the hands of government,
if you don't take that ring away from
Gollum and throw it into mount zoom,
then it will be used against you.
There will.
The government is just government is the
rate.
So does this.
I my direct message at the top of the
show,
I was talking about just how stupid our
election system is and how everything's
down to soundbites and everything in our
debate is so nonsensical and all that.
So everything you just laid out there is
a much more clean and clear explanation
and where you actually are separating
church and state and doing the
intellectual rigor to,
to make a sensible argument where if
they talk for the little bit that
they've talked about gay marriage,
which I'm glad because I don't think it
should be talked about that much.
It let it be and that that will be fine
in my opinion.
Um,
but nobody,
you know,
Marco Rubio,
we'll talk about the family,
but he's purely doing it from a
religious perspective.
Well,
there's an identity politics that's been
created on the right in response to the
identity politics of the left.
So if we're going to be attacked as
religious people,
we have to talk as religious people.
I have to go preach from a pulpit and if
I don't cite,
you know,
if I don't say genesis to talk about a
man shall leave his,
a man shall leave his parents and cling
to his wife.
If I don't.
If I don't cite that,
then I haven't spoken to the incode that
shows that I care about the values of
people.
Like you and the,
and this is the way the political game
is played,
so again,
I sort of wished that Americans would
see through the political game on all
sides,
meaning I wish religious people would
just say,
I agree.
I understand you're anti gay marriage
and I also understand what you're doing
here to protect religious people and you
don't have to cite Bible verses at me to
prove it and it and you end up with
idiocies like Donald Trump on stage
waving around a bible,
pretending he gives a damn what's in it,
ms dot two after two marriages and
several adulterous affairs and all the
and bragging about having his
experiences with married women standing
up there with the Bible and going,
this is an even better book than the out
of the deal is if this is,
this is how you vote.
If you're able to be pandered to that
way,
that's a sad commentary on American
politics and in its way.
It's really no different from Hillary
Clinton going to the black community and
saying,
you're the victims.
You're the victims,
and now I'm going to speak the language.
You understand?
Here's,
here's how you know that I care about
you.
I'm not big into caring,
you know,
I'm not,
I,
I think that people who presumed to care
about you are generally people who want
the power to control your life.
The only people that,
that I want power in their lives and
they want power in my life or my
immediate family.
That's it.
You know,
my parents,
my sisters,
my wife,
my children,
and their independent human beings too.
Right?
So caring,
caring is the,
is the way that caring is the way that
the left controls.
Like they never,
they don't come with the Jack boots
first.
They first come and they say,
we care so much about you.
We have to do these things for you.
And by the way,
we brought some guns to help out.
Right?
So it shows sort of the beauty or the
scariness of identity politics because
it sounds really good.
I guess what they always say,
socialism will come with a big smile,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
This is John Goldberg's point in Liberal
Fascism.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
so we only have a couple minutes left,
but let's do it.
Let's just knock out a couple of other
things.
So I saw when you were on piers Morgan
with that whole gun thing way back when
and I watched it again in preparation
for this and I never liked piers Morgan.
I thought he was doing a talk.
Show you the wrong way.
I hope people don't view me in that way,
but what you did with him in the
argument was really kind of brilliant
and it goes to,
it goes to some of the 11th before.
But before even ladies,
anything,
I don't really agree with your,
with your stance on guns.
Um,
so can you sort of recap happened and
then we'll show
her?
Well,
first of all,
like trump,
now that you've complimented me like
gluten free person,
now you're a good person.
I read the,
it's all good.
So what,
what happened in that debate is that
piers Morgan had basically been doing a
lot of the things we're talking about
for weeks.
You'd been saying after Sandy Hook that
anybody who disagreed with him on gun
control,
the only possible reason to disagree
with him is because you don't care about
what happened on gun control and you saw
Barack Obama do this,
you know,
after the,
after the last mass shooting right after
Umpqua community college and he got up
there and,
and he,
he did the teary eyed routine and I
don't like tears.
Stop.
Like just,
just give me your policy.
So what.
So what I said to the tiers,
I think design in a weird way.
I don't.
It is tiring out over here.
Bama,
and I think Obama is an unusually
skilled politician and I think he worked
himself up to tears.
I think that I think that good actors
can.
I think that,
you know,
the,
the idea that the emotion is fake is
that I don't think they motions fake,
but the emotional factors isn't fake
either.
If you talked to actors who work
themselves up to tears,
they actually feel sad when they are
crying.
That's how you get yourself to cry.
Right.
I think Obama worked himself up there
because otherwise you'd be fine.
Otherwise you'd be crying every other
press conference.
I mean,
he's talking about all sorts of crap
that goes on in the country.
That's terrible.
Like how many.
Every time he gets out there and you
talked about the economy be crying.
I mean,
you'd be completely emotionally
unstable.
It's one of the two.
So it's.
So,
uh,
so what I said to Piers Morgan is I said
you're a bully and the way that you
bullied people as you stand on the
graves of the children of Sandy Hook to
push her political agenda.
And he didn't know how to come back from
that because that was his entire
strategy and now it had been unmasked.
And actually during the break he had
planned to bring in a kid who had been
shot and was in a wheelchair and say,
well,
you've said it to me now.
Say it to the small pool,
a child.
And he couldn't do it because if you've
done that,
I immediately would have said,
first you stood on the graves of the
kids and now you're standing on this
poor guy's wheelchair.
It's terrible.
But it's so.
So that was sort of the content of the
argument he tried to.
He tried to throw the.
The Ronald Reagan was in favor of
banning assault weapons at me.
I don't care as I've said what Ronald
Reagan had to say.
He was a guy.
Sometimes he's right.
Sometimes he's wrong.
So he wasn't a God.
Is that?
Yeah,
exactly.
That,
that has a religious person.
I only have one and got him.
Yeah,
exactly.
So that's not the one we knew that I
knew there was more.
Right.
It's just not Reagan.
Reagan.
Okay,
got it.
And I know,
cause he's not back.
Right.
He could be,
he could be weird.
But.
So.
So my feelings on the gun thing is that
basically,
because I believe in the second
amendment,
people should have access to guns.
As you clear.
It's clear after an hour together.
I'm not a huge fan of the government,
so I do believe people should be able to
protect themselves and all of those
things.
What I think is that we're.
We should be able to control it a little
bit more than we are a.
I think that the NRA does wield too much
power and then I would say at the same
time as I always say,
two things can be true.
At the same time.
We have a massive mental health problem
in this country and that's the part that
we're not talking about because every
commercial for every cable news channel
is for some other drug that it turns out
that some crazy percentage of these
shooters are on.
Right?
So when it comes to gun violence,
there's two problems.
There's an inner city violence which
really is,
is a matter of gang violence and and
people shooting each other unfortunately
because they're.
Because they're involved in gangs and
it's happening every day in Chicago,
but we've never actually.
And Los Angeles and Washington DC and
all the major cities.
I mean this is all the heavily gun
controlled areas,
democratic areas.
These are the places where people are
getting killed on mass and then you have
the mass shooting issue and the mass
shooting issue is largely because in the
19 sixties,
in 19 seventies,
this is the one area where I think the
government actually should be involved
in the 19 sixties in 19 seventies there
was a decision that was made basically
all across the country to empty out all
the mental facilities because there was
an idea that went around the country and
gained a lot of traction.
That mental illness was basically one
flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Nobody was seriously crazy.
Everybody was just eccentric and this is
why you have a mass growth and homeless
people.
In 1960 there are.
How many people do you think in 1960
were in mental institutions in the
United States?
I mean,
I can't imagine.
I would guess half a million or half a
million.
Half a million people.
Right.
And we had half the population.
Then right?
Today there's 25,000
people in mental facilities.
So you've got a lot of violent people on
the streets and so you have a lot of
island people on the streets.
You're going to end up with more mass
shootings and that's why every time
there's a mass shooting,
almost invariably it's somebody who is
crazy and we've known they're crazy and
involuntary commitment laws are really,
really difficult because you have to
show that the person is a threat to
themselves or others as opposed to the
old standard which was they're incapable
of caring for themselves.
One of the big problems with paranoid
schizophrenia,
which is flooded a lot of these shooters
a is that you have the.
You have a condition where you literally
can't even recognize that you have the
condition,
so you won't take your drugs if we let
you out and you'll just go off the drugs
and you'll go right back to doing what
it was that you were doing in the first
week.
And the drugs often is part of the
people that are off the drugs and it's
people that are on most of the.
Most of the people who are committing
these acts are not on heavy medication.
these acts are people who have gone off
their medication and they have
significant mental illness and they need
to be medicated.
So you know,
this is an area where the,
the mental health system is dramatically
underfunded.
The laws are complete when it comes to
people who legitimately cannot take care
of themselves.
I'm talking and I'm speaking as somebody
whose grandfather was,
was a schizophrenia who went into a
mental hospital.
They gave them lithium and then he spent
the rest of his life as a happy,
productive human being,
right?
The,
these,
these are things that might not have
been possible now.
And then.
So this is,
you know,
this is an area where I,
I actually think that there's,
there,
there is a role for the government in
this because this is John Locke would
have thought the same.
John Locke said this in,
in,
in his writings,
he said that,
you know,
the problem of mental illnesses.
One that sort of falls on society as a
whole because you have a group of people
who can't take care of themselves.
That's the real problem with mass
shootings,
you know,
taking my guns away from me or taking
another law abiding person's,
gotten away from them,
that's not going to stop the mass
shooter.
Uh,
in fact it's probably going to create
more mass shootings because now I can't
defend myself.
So would you say the NRA is a problem at
all in,
in,
within the thing,
the NRA is incredibly valuable
organization because it's pushing
against people on the other side.
I don't have to agree with everything
the NRA says to think that they are an
incredibly valuable organization that's
channeling,
uh,
the,
the legal hopes of a lot of Americans to
protect the second amendment.
And we're about one vote away on the
Supreme Court from the Second Amendment
disappearing entirely.
So let's just do some stuff in that.
That's how it,
that's how we can add this.
So with this whole thing with Scalia
right now and this spot,
where do you stand on this?
It seems to me that Obama has to
nominate someone that's his job.
He's the president,
he's the president right now.
He can,
he doesn't have to,
but,
and if it was a republican,
of course he was okay.
And now that it's up and I don't care if
he does,
as you say,
he has the capacity to do it.
It's one of the things that he's
actually allowed to do as president that
he's doing as opposed to all the other
things he's doing,
which she's not allowed to do,
but we've got to finish up so we have to
focus on this one.
So.
All right,
so we're in agreement on that.
And then they say it will be up to the
Senate to either confirm this person or
not.
They don't have to give him an up or
down vote though,
right?
You can do whatever they want.
So what do you make of,
of the,
you know,
Mitch Mcconnell and the rest of these
guys that are like,
ah,
you know,
he shouldn't even nominate anybody and
all that.
I think it's an idiotic line of
argument.
I mean,
I think it's a really dumb line of
argument was I wrote my,
I went to Harvard law school and I wrote
my third year paper at Harvard law
school on the idea that Marbury versus
Madison was wrongly decided.
I don't think that the supreme court
should have the capacity to decide for
everyone,
like for conservatives to think that the
entire future of the constitution
restaurants,
skulled one guy not dying is really sad.
Right?
And,
and,
and the reason for that is because the
supreme court has now been seen as this
great moral arbiter.
I don't think it is.
I think that the supreme court has been
responsible for some of the worst
decision in,
in human history.
I mean,
the supreme court is responsible for
row,
which is a disaster.
The supreme court was responsible for
plessy versus Ferguson.
Everybody always wants to talk about
Brown versus board.
If they'd gotten plessy right in the
first place,
you don't need brown versus board and
segregation ends in 1900.
So this is.
So the,
the supreme court is a,
is a serious problem there.
Nine unelected people,
which I don't even care about the
unelected,
but their their nine people who are
given the power to control everybody's
life in the name of a document that most
of them don't even take seriously.
Is that the irony with the Supreme Court
that they're supposed to be above
partisan politics and yet the whole
system to get them there is part of and
then they're part of seeing themselves.
I mean a lightening.
Kagan is a hardcore Democrat.
Elena Kagan was the solicitor general
for,
for Barack Obama.
Come on,
right?
I mean I.
I went to the.
She was the dean when I was at Harvard
law school.
She was a hardcore leftist.
Then you know the idea that people are
free of politics and what they call
legal realist.
I believe that that means that virtually
everybody is,
is,
has their perspective on life and that
comes out in how they and how they
adjudicate a and you have to work very
hard to remove yourself from that.
I think most judges don't.
I think most judges rule based on what
they feel like Anthony Kennedy,
you can't tell them regardless what you
think about same sex marriage.
You cannot tell me that the constitution
of the United States or the 14th
amendment there too,
which was ratified in 18,
68,
was demanding that the state's not
passed laws in favor of traditional
marriage.
That's absurd.
It's absurd.
No,
but he but equal protection.
He was using that or protection or that
we should all be treated equally.
It's a bunch of crap because equal
protection does not mean that.
That,
that everybody,
that a law should have an equal effect
on everyone.
No law has an equal effect on everyone.
The question is whether the law itself,
whether the law itself discriminates
against someone on the basis of an
immutable characteristic,
and one of the problems with,
with the whole gays are blacks,
is that gays are not black.
I mean the fact is that a gay person who
has sex with another man is not going to
manifest their homosexuality in a way
that society cares about.
They may be gay,
they may have sex addicts to shoot up a
place.
Well maybe,
maybe he will.
Maybe he won't.
I mean,
I assume that there,
I assume that for the last couple of
hundred,
a couple of thousand years when gays
were not treated well in Western
society,
that not all the scrutiny gay people
were going and killing folks more
capable than that.
I think that,
you know,
the,
the gay people have the same selfcontrol
the straight people do.
I don't think there are any better.
I don't think they're any worse in terms
of their sexual self control.
And I will say that I think men in
general are less good in terms of sexual
assault control than women's.
So,
which explains why,
which is why gay men have sex with more
people than,
than straight men because women don't
want to have sex with men as much as
men.
Wanna have sex with men have strong sex
drive.
So yeah,
but that's well off topic.
Back to the Scalia for a second.
The the problem here is that the
Republican Party,
when they say things like,
it's the timeline,
it isn't the timeline,
okay.
If somebody replaces Justice Scalia who
off the left and I don't care one,
this is if hillary gets elected,
if we're,
if we're 20 years from now,
one more vote on the Supreme Court and
the left is on the court,
do not see the constitution as a piece
of law,
right?
To be interpreted like the Sherman
antitrust act or obamacare.
They see the.
They see the constitution as a piece of
poetry to be interpreted as their
feelings dictate and this is the point
that I'm making about Kennedy through
line,
through everything we're talking.
That's right,
and this is the point that I'm making
about Kennedy specifically in the gay
marriage decision.
There is not one iota of evidence that
the law that when it was written meant
anything to this effect or that it meant
to leave an open space for the Supreme
Court to come in and leverage down on
states.
Same sex marriage laws mean what they
mean when they're written.
They don't mean what they are,
what they mean to a hundred years from
now.
If somebody picks up this interview in
200 years and starts to read into my
perspective that I'm super pro
homosexual behavior,
I would be a little bit surprised,
right?
But that's essentially what happened in
18,
68.
He's taking a clause that was written by
a bunch of people who were very much not
in favor of even forget homosexual
marriage who criminalized sodomy,
right?
And saying to them,
okay,
well those people really meant what they
really meant here was pro same sex
marriage.
If you want to make same sex marriage,
legal make illegal,
you know,
that's.
That's what you can do through the
ballot box is the beauty of a republic,
but you don't get to have nine unelected
judges.
Who are these special moral people
who've been dinged by the hand of God?
I don't believe.
I believe all human beings are capable
of good.
of evil.
I believe all human beings are selfish
and all of our are capable of altruism.
I don't believe that there are nine
perfect human beings who sit on the
supreme court and rule us as a magical
angelica oligarchy.
I think that's a pretty solid ending to
this.
What do you think?
Sounds good to me.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
I think what we did here was exactly
what I want this to be,
that we don't have to agree on
everything,
but I do sense a sort of new center
coming together with people that are on
the right.
That was my left,
but it's there people that are on the
left and on the right that there's a way
where you can be moral and it doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with
religion or you can be moral and it has
to do with religion,
but that's not how you want to be
governed and I think that's gonna be my
takeaway.
I think that's exactly right.
I mean,
as I say to people who disagree with me,
the of the countries that you don't have
to care what I think the minute you
bring the government into saying that I
have to care what you think,
then we're at odds.
So as long as the government is out of
it.
We didn't have these discussions all day
long and it's just good fun.
The minute you bring the gun to the
party or the fascist,
more importantly than any of that,
Milo Yiannopoulos is going to be so
jealous that we sat here for an hour
anyway.
I want to thank a band and you can check
out his work pretty much all over the
place,
but I believe it's Benjamin Shapiro doc
and go to daily wire is probably the
best place to get a wire.com
and he's doing the breitbart thing and
all that.
Thank you guys for watching and we'll do
it again next week.